[Music]
back in 1958 Around the World in 80 Days
won five Academy Awards including the
Oscar for Best Picture the lighthearted
Adventure based on the Jules Verne novel
follows a Victorian age gentleman as he
tries to circle the globe to settle a
bet now the story is inspiring two
friends to make a similar Trip Around
the World in 80 Days and they're doing
it in their 80s Remy inocencio caught up
with them on their Journey
for Sandy hayslip and Ellie Hamby this
is the adventure of their lifetimes
already well lived exploring Easter
Island with statues that have seen a
millennium of sunsets piercing polar
waves in the Antarctic
to share the shore with emperor penguins
at 81 years old these best friends from
Abilene Texas are whizzing Around the
World in 80 Days their goal all seven
continents 18 countries nine world
wonders what was the inspiration I think
the number one thing is meeting people
we love people we just love to talk to
people and the world is full of the
greatest the most exciting most
interesting people we met in London on a
quick Transit and they shared a secret
we both have total knee Replacements and
here you're walking around the whole
world oh no we're great no issues
whatsoever oh do you think we got any
issues so we all do
Ellie is a documentary photographer and
runs a medical mission in Zambia Sandy a
physician and hospice caregiver they met
two decades ago in Africa and just
clicked two peas in a pod is there a
certain pair of ladies that you both
identify with together Lucian and in
Ethel
we have been told that before before
this around the world trip they've
beamed their smiles through China Russia
Cambodia and the Syrian desert adapting
to adversities along the way their
original plan Around the World in 80
Days at the age of 80 was delayed twice
because of covid their new motto age 81
is still on the Run we decided long ago
just go with the flow smile number one
absolutely always smile don't get upset
with anyone just smile they pack light
and travel cheap they even slept in an
airport to catch a flight to see the
Northern Lights we don't travel first
class and so when we have other ladies
especially who say oh I would love to
travel with you too the first thing I
always do is look at their hands if they
are well manicured they do not want to
travel with us let me see your
fingernails they're fine what are you
talking about
for people who say I'm too old to do
what you're doing what do you say to
that don't sit in that chair and waste
away if you don't use it you lose it
footloose and fancy free they're losing
no time at all to travel to the ends of
the Earth together cheers to both of you
for CBS Saturday morning Remy inocencio
London
what's not to love there and the power
of friendship too and able to do it
together and share the experiences it's
remarkable that how uh how flexible they
are for everything and I love that no
first class or sleeping at the airports
check out your nails you got to make
sure that you can go with the flow use
it or lose it right 80 to 81 and still
on the Run get this take a look now
Ellie and Sandy actually shared their
latest adventure with us this morning
just today they boarded a plane in Nepal
soaring high above the world's tallest
peak Mount Everest my God ladies what a
way to getting it done what a way to
live lesson to us all love it Randy
thank you for that story